Everybody knows Deadpool has a mutant healing
factor.
That's kind of his thing.
It's no secret that he's aware he's a fictional
character, either — breaking the fourth
wall is what set Deadpool apart from all those
other grizzled, bulky, pouch-wearing '90s
tough guys, and made him into the wise-cracking
antihero he is today.
But the Marvel Universe is lousy with mutants
that can heal themselves — besides Deadpool
there's Wolverine, Sabretooth, Mystique, and
X-23, just to name a few — and Wade Wilson
needed more if he was ever going to get ahead.
Thankfully, Deadpool has plenty of other tricks
up his sleeve.
Here are a few.
Master of disguise
Deadpool is tough, funny, and charming, but
let's face it: he's not exactly a looker.
The experimental surgery that gave Wade Wilson
his regenerative powers also kicked his cancer
into overdrive.
And while the procedure kept tumors from ravaging
his body, it didn't keep them from growing
all over his face.
As a result, Deadpool looks like, well...
"Like a testicle with teeth."
His words, not ours.
Anyway, he understandably prefers not to show
his face in public.
So when he's on the job, that isn't much of
a problem.
Put a mask over that gruesome mug and nobody
can tell the difference.
But, to hit the town, he has to get creative.
In the comics, Deadpool uses a holographic
image inducer and disguises to change his
appearance and wander around incognito.
Deadpool also employs the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles' proven, low-tech disguise: a hat,
a trenchcoat, and the comforting knowledge
that in New York City, a tumor-infested weirdo
probably won't be the weirdest thing you'll
see wandering the streets.
Teleportation
Deadpool can't fly, and doesn't have super
speed.
So, what's a busy mercenary to do when he
has to get somewhere in a hurry?
In the movie, he takes a taxi.
But that doesn't make for very exciting comics
and, as the film version of Deadpool proved,
Wade's not always great at keeping track of
his belongings.
Yep, the guns were in that taxi.
As a result, Deadpool has used a number of
teleportation devices to get around quickly
in the comics.
In the early issues of Deadpool, he has a
device tucked away in one of his many pouches
which allows him to zip around with ease.
Then, he even biologically combined with Cable
for a while in the Cable & Deadpool series
due to a crazy virus, which allowed him to
share Cable’s teleportation tech.
Hard to get drunk
Deadpool's healing factor is pretty handy.
It stops cancer.
It cures decapitation.
It lets him walk away from fights with creatures
like the Hulk, and it kicks his metabolism
into overdrive.
That's right: no matter how much he eats,
Deadpool won't gain any weight.
That's all good news when you're fighting
supervillains, but isn't so useful when you
want to get absolutely hammered — and, let's
face it, Wade is the kind of guy who could
use a drink every now and then.
But, Deadpool can get drunk.
He just needs a lot of alcohol to make it
happen.
In Deadpool #12, Wade spends an entire day
and night drinking before he's even slightly
buzzed.
In Deadpool #7, a villain pays Deadpool to
make Iron Man drunk, but instead of forcing
Tony Stark off the wagon, Deadpool takes care
of business himself.
Wade clocks Stark with a liquor bottle and
straps into the Iron Man armor, but not before
downing an entire sack full of stolen booze.
That fulfills Wade's contract — Iron Man
had to get plastered, not Tony — and best
of all, Deadpool doesn't even have a hangover
when he wakes up.
Now that's a superpower.
Superhuman strength
Deadpool is able to lift between 800 to 50,000
pounds, but you wouldn't know it just by looking
at him.
While super-strength is one of Deadpool's
many powers, you rarely see him lifting heavy
objects, and the only time Wade seems to make
use of his enhanced abilities is when he goes
toe-to-toe with heavyweights like the Hulk
and the Juggernaut.
Still, every once in awhile, somebody hints
that Deadpool is a lot stronger than he seems.
During his earliest appearances, he went toe-to-toe
with some of Marvel's strongest characters.
In X-Force #11, Shatterstar, a warrior from
the Mojoverse with super-strength, calls Deadpool
his equal — right before Deadpool knocks
him out cold.
In X-Force #15, Wade is powerful enough to
kick Cable's head through a stone wall.
Deadpool's super-strength is made abundantly
clear in Cable & Deadpool #13.
Haji Bin Barat, one of the world's most deadly
terrorists, is murdered, and Deadpool wants
to solve the case.
As Deadpool gathers clues, the medical examiner
concludes that Barat was choked by an adult
male using just two fingers.
In fact, the murderer actually squeezed too
hard, accidentally snapping Barat's neck mid-killing,
a feat that would require superhuman strength.
At the same time, Deadpool discovers that
he's the murderer—he just can't immediately
remember why he did it.
Because, you know, comics.
Cursed to be immortal
Thanos, one of the biggest bads in a galaxy
full of big bads, has the hots for Death — as
in, the literal personification of mortality
— and he'll do practically anything to prove
it.
So, as you can imagine, Thanos isn't exactly
thrilled when Death and Deadpool strike up
a relationship.
In Deadpool/Death Annual '98, Wade first meets
Thanos' would-be gal pal when he's stuck in
the Department K medical facility, undergoing
the treatments that will eventually turn him
into Deadpool.
Thanks to his cancer and the government's
experiments, Wade is very, very close to dying,
and Death uses her feminine wiles to try and
convince Wade to finish the job.
However, Wade's newfound healing powers—and
a reluctant sense of heroism—foil his best
attempts at suicide-by-supervillain, and the
couple is forced apart.
Later, to keep Deadpool away from Death, Thanos
puts a curse on Wade that brings him back
to life whenever he dies—and will keep him
that way.
Resistant to psychic attacks
Wade’s inability to die isn’t his real
superpower.
His insanity is.
Deadpool knows he's a comic book character
because he's absolutely crazy, and while his
broken psyche doesn't help much when it comes
to getting a happy ending, it's a huge boon
when he faces off against psychics.
For example, in Deadpool #69, Deadpool finds
himself in a duel with a telepathic mutant
known as the Black Swan.
As they fight, Swan tries to poke around in
Wade's head to find the disarm code for a
bomb Deadpool brought with him.
Unfortunately for Swan, things don't work
exactly like he expected.
Wade welcomes Swan into his mind, which is
a savagely insane place.
That distracts Swan long enough for Deadpool
to shove the villain's head in the fireplace.
Deadpool attempts to defuse the bomb.
But it goes off anyway.
Because, hey, Deadpool’s not great with
details.
Deadpool's healing powers help fight against
telepathy, too.
In Cable & Deadpool #8, the X-Men enlist Deadpool
to help stop Cable, who's trying to create
peace by uniting the world's nations against
a common enemy—himself.
Emma Frost, a psychic, uses Cerebro to shield
the X-Men from Cable's telepathy, but Deadpool
has an easier way: they could've just had
the conversation inside his brain, which is
immune to telepathy thanks to its ever-changing
biology.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!